ALAN SEALES: Now here to discuss
their first book, "Dream Home,"
please welcome Jonathan
and Drew Scott.
[APPLAUSE]
DREW SCOTT: Well,
thank you, sir.
ALAN SEALES: Welcome.
Have a seat.
Or you can sit
here, if you want.
JONATHAN SCOTT: The fact
that you dressed like me
is just so nice-- it's so kind.
ALAN SEALES: It was
actually my wife's idea.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, yeah?
Is she dressing you, still?
JONATHAN SCOTT: I prefer a suit.
DREW SCOTT: Are you in here?
JONATHAN SCOTT: You should
be in a suit like me.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
She's back there.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, hi.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, hello.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Love you.
DREW SCOTT: I would prefer if
you dress him like me, not him.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oof.
DREW SCOTT: Well,
yeah, if you're
a fan of "Property
Brothers," why aren't you
fan-girling more?
I wanted to hear
more high-pitched
squealing out of you.
ALAN SEALES:
(SQUEALING) Oh, my god.
It's the Property Brothers.
DREW SCOTT: That's it.
JONATHAN SCOTT: We did a talk.
We were in Minneapolis.
And there was-- not that I'm
bragging-- about 4,000 people
showed up.
[LAUGHING]
ALAN SEALES: We can't fit
that many in this room.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So it
was a big convention.
It was a big amphitheater.
We were in there and we
were doing our talk, I mean.
And when we first
walked up, there
was cheering and
cheering and cheering.
There's always that one person
who's late to the party.
And so just as everyone
was dying down,
this one voice booms
out, (DEEP VOICE) Yeah!
So we've got, like, a sea
of 3,999 women and one dude.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, it was
all, I said, so who here,
let's be honest-- because most
of our die-hard fans know that
he's single [PURR]--
JONATHAN SCOTT: (LAUGHING) Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: And so I'm like,
who here's Team Jonathan?
You hear all the girls scream.
And then, I'm like,
who here is Team Dew?
Literally, in a crowd
of 4,000 people,
one dude's like,
(DEEP VOICE) Drew!
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: Like, thanks, man.
Got you back.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I'd
keep an eye on that guy.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I just want to
point out, I have those socks.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, do you?
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
DREW SCOTT: I am a sock guy.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Do you have
the matching underwear?
ALAN SEALES: I have my--
my wrench socks on today.
DREW SCOTT: The wrench?
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
DREW SCOTT: You should be
wearing the wrench socks.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I don't even
know what I dressed myself
with today.
DREW SCOTT: I'm wearing--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, well,
they're still in there.
DREW SCOTT: I'm wearing my
wrench underwear, though.
It's--
JONATHAN SCOTT:
No, you sit down.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: By the
way, is anyone else
in here wearing a suit and tie?
Or, is Drew the only one?
DREW SCOTT: Yes.
Our producer, back there,
somebody in the back.
I like your style.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So we went
to Nashville for the CMA.
We were hosting CMA last
year-- country music festival.
120 degrees out, and Drew
wore a three-piece suit
to a country music festival.
DREW SCOTT: So?
JONATHAN SCOTT: And
I'm, like, the only guy.
And I got on a bucking bull.
And he jumped.
He has to outdo me.
And even if I'm walking to
the car, he has to outdo me.
And he jumps on the
bucking bull, rips
the ass out of his
pants, and he had, like,
fuchsia underwear on.
Drew brought fuchsia
to Nashville.
And Getty was right on it.
DREW SCOTT: Yep.
There we go.
Do I look more Google-esque?
ALAN SEALES: There you go.
DREW SCOTT: Google-esque.
ALAN SEALES: There, I
untied your tie for you.
So you're actually here
to discuss your book.
DREW SCOTT: Yes.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, right.
ALAN SEALES: So this
is your first book,
"Dream Home, the Property
Brothers' Ultimate
Guide to Finding and
Fixing Your Perfect House."
I found it incredibly
helpful for me.
I'm in the process of looking
for a townhouse in Brooklyn.
So I want to hire you guys.
I hope you're available.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Done.
DREW SCOTT: Let me
ask one question.
Wife?
Is he handy?
AUDIENCE: Yes, he is handy.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, really.
I'm looking to replace Jonathan.
JONATHAN SCOTT: All right.
Good.
ALAN SEALES: We've
got the stubble going.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah,
I was going to say,
you're, like, literally
cloning Jonathan today.
You could be the other brother.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
What would you say
is the one thing
that stood out to you
that was, right off the top,
you're like-- oh, obviously.
Yeah, that's good.
That helps.
ALAN SEALES: Making a list
between the must-haves
and the nice-to-haves.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yes.
Which is true.
So when we-- whenever
we're sitting--
and this is how the
book came to be.
So we've been doing
this for 20 years.
Coming out of high
school, we started
investing in real estate.
And we're like, we didn't
want to be struggling artists,
actors.
He's a director.
I'm a magician.
So we're like, we want to
fund our creative efforts
with a real estate.
DREW SCOTT: No big deal.
Yeah, yeah, I'm a magician.
Anyway, so--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
No big deal.
Kapow!
I always carry one
of those smoke bombs
with me, just in case.
Anyway, so we wanted to make
sure that we knew everything.
So we read every book
we could on real estate.
I even watched the
infomercials with the guy
with the babes and boats.
And I'm like, oh, I could
have babes and boats.
Still don't have it.
So we thought, we want to
take this compilation of all
the information we've
learned all the years,
any mistakes we made when
we were starting out,
prevent other people
from making them,
and really have one guide
that helps everybody.
In the process, as we were
doing those live lectures,
like in Minneapolis,
we realized--
we would ask an auditorium
4,000 people, and we'd be like,
how many of you did this with
your real estate professional
when you were looking to buy?
And go through the checklist
of all the questions
you have to ask yourself.
And of 4,000 people, there would
maybe be 10 hands that go up.
So that's when we said, well,
then there needs to be a guide.
There needs to be something
simple that people can follow.
DREW SCOTT: That's
when we realized
that homeowners are dumb.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yes.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, I mean, no.
I didn't say that.
No.
I'm just joking.
They're ignorant to how to
maximize their investment, how
to make sure they're
protecting themselves,
and what to do for design.
99% of people out there don't
know how to design a space.
They can know that they
love this big open room,
but what do I do with it?
So that's why we
came out with the--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well, and
it's overwhelming, too.
Because we have
it, as well, where
we'll have clients that come to
us that are first-time buyers,
and you know it's scary.
Like, they don't
know what to expect,
and this is the biggest
investment of their lives,
and what do I do?
And if they're not even paired
with the right professional--
sometimes they've worked
with other real estate
professionals who are, like,
fast-talking city Realtors.
You can't-- you have to find
someone who works at the same
pace that you do--
DREW SCOTT: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN SCOTT: --and
will answer questions.
If you're ever-- one of the
other things in the book
is, if you're ever working with
a professional-- contractor,
lawyer, Realtor,
whatever-- who makes
you feel like an idiot
for asking a question,
you are working with
the wrong person.
You're in charge.
You're driving the ship.
This is your money.
So you want to make
sure that you're
going to be happy at
the end of the day.
ALAN SEALES: That's the
culture we promote here, too.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
There you go.
See, I should get a job here.
ALAN SEALES: A team lead should
not make you feel like a jerk
for asking a question.
DREW SCOTT: Never.
No, what's-- I've never heard
someone say that the best way
to learn is to have a boss who
is a jerk and belittles you
every minute.
Or, wait.
Have I heard that before?
I don't know.
That's what he does to me.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: But, yeah.
Exactly.
We like to inspire--
JONATHAN SCOTT: We're siblings.
ALAN SEALES: Have you worked
with people like that?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, yeah.
There's a mentality,
sometimes, with people-- hey,
I'm the one who works every day.
So there the mentality
that some people
like to lead by intimidation.
I don't think that's successful.
I think that's a
very short-term goal,
but it doesn't lead
to-- we're very similar.
And, actually, it was a
tour that we had done ages
ago with Google, as
well, that-- we wanted
to create for our office,
Scott Brothers Entertainment,
an environment where people
wanted to come and work.
We do fun things.
I mean, we just had all
of our employees-- suck
on this, Google-- we booked
out an entire cruise ship
and took 2,000 fans and all
of our staff and everybody
through the Caribbean
for four days.
And it was great.
It's great just to do
things outside of the office
space that help you bond.
Because then, when
so-and-so hits you up,
when you're in a rush and
you need something real fast,
you're a little more
willing to do it,
because you guys have bonded.
DREW SCOTT: I'm
pretty sure Google
owned the ship and
the island we went to.
I'm just saying.
JONATHAN SCOTT: That's true.
That's correct.
ALAN SEALES: Well, you've
touched on some of this
already, but I wanted to kind of
get back into how you started.
Like, so Drew, you're a Realtor.
Jonathan, contractor.
You're both business owners.
You were both actors or,
obviously, still are,
at this point.
Because you guys are--
DREW SCOTT: We still
do some acting.
And, I mean, that acting
background and our improv--
we did sketch comedy.
So I'll back up, I'll tell
you a bit of that story.
So as actors,
magician, director,
we had these creative
outlets, but we
didn't want to be struggling
talent, struggling artists.
And so what we-- yeah,
that's the biggest trick
he has is his thumb trick.
Anyway, so what we wanted
to do is make some money,
so we can make our own films,
and do our own endeavors,
and not have to worry
about being penny-to-penny.
And we heard real estate was
a great way to make money.
So, at the time, we were
in Canada-- at the time,
we heard the Calgary
market was really booming.
So we moved, when we
graduated high school.
First of all, we read every
book we possibly could,
every VHS tape we could get.
I'm dating myself.
For you guys at
Google-- you don't
know-- a VHS is a thick DVD,
which is a-- never mind.
Anyway, so yeah,
we got every bit
of information, those
late infomercials,
and then we learned
what we could.
We bought our first place
right out of high school.
It was a $200,000 house.
We used creative financing and
got it for a $250 down payment.
ALAN SEALES: You were
18 when you did this.
DREW SCOTT: At 18.
Yeah, and then we
did a lit-- actually,
barely anything to that house.
We barely renovated the place.
We sold it after a
year for a $50k profit,
and we thought, OK, we
can start to do this.
So we continue, continue.
Eventually, friends
were asking us
to invest and help them
renovate some houses for them.
So that's when we thought,
let's be professional.
JONATHAN SCOTT: That
was the biggest thing
that we discovered
is, most people have
a very tunnel vision
view-- and it's
because it's been
drummed into their mind--
a very tunnel vision
view about how
you can invest in real estate,
how you can buy real estate.
Some people don't want to
have a bunch of real estate,
they just want to
own their own home.
And some people want to be the
next mogul of-- real estate
mogul of New York.
DREW SCOTT: They want to
be (TRUMP VOICE) huge.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
They want to be huge.
DREW SCOTT: (TRUMP VOICE)
Huge with their real estate.
ALAN SEALES: Key
political point.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So
that's what we said is,
it's about looking
outside the box.
There are government
programs that
can offer you grants and
things toward renovations.
There are programs,
as well, that
will make it easier
to get a home
and to get approved
for financing.
So that's what we did.
We found the ability
to assume a mor--
you used to be able to assume
a mortgage without qualifying.
So if somebody couldn't
afford to pay their mortgage--
DREW SCOTT: Very smart.
Two, just out of high school--
two full-time students
buying a house for $250.
Nothing could go wrong.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So
we were fortunate.
You can't do that anymore.
But we were fortunate
that we put the effort
into looking at all of our
options, and it paid off.
So the book is the same thing.
It's about asking you--
it's about getting
you to ask the questions that
you need to ask yourself.
Because, at the end of
the day, our philosophy
is that your home should
make your life easier.
So, you know, whether you--
say, you have four kids,
and you spend half your
life doing laundry.
Well, maybe it's worth
putting a little more money
into the laundry
facilities in your home,
because who knew you could get
an extra-large capacity washer
and dryer that'll do a 15-minute
wash, 15-minute dry, done.
Well, then you don't have to
spend the entire weekend doing
laundry.
So there's all these little
things that-- I know this,
and most contractors and
designers know this--
but the average
homeowner doesn't.
ALAN SEALES: Mm-hm.
So I want to go back to the
magician thing for a second.
Because you keep saying that
and people keep giggling.
JONATHAN SCOTT: All right.
ALAN SEALES: Like, I will come
back to the homeowner stuff,
but I'm going to
talk about-- you're
an actual certified magician.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Certified.
ALAN SEALES: "Certified."
DREW SCOTT: Yes.
DREW SCOTT: You went
to a magic school.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I have
a degree in magicianing.
I don't know.
ALAN SEALES: Magicianography?
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Yes, so I started--
we actually both started when
we were eight years old--
DREW SCOTT: Six or seven.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yes.
Seven years old, we
were apprentice clowns.
And I'm not kidding.
So we actually--
ALAN SEALES: That
was not in the book.
JONATHAN SCOTT: No,
it's not in the book.
So, we were actually--
we were overachievers
since we were born.
And so our dad said to us,
you're seven years old.
Get a job.
So I remember looking through
the paper with my dad.
DREW SCOTT: Literally.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And there was
a wanted thing that people
to go to clown school.
At parks and rec, they
had, like, a clown program.
And then, after that,
when you were "certified,"
they would put you out for
parades and stuff like that.
So we were these two
kids-- tall, gangly kids.
When you have the
makeup on, nobody
can tell how old you are.
And we got hired do parades,
and birthday parties,
and all kinds of stuff.
By the time we were 12, we were
making, like, $50 bucks an hour
doing a couple birthday
parties a weekend.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah,
one here, one there.
But it was pretty good for us.
It was a fun outlet.
My parents were like, do it.
Because they're so
energetic at home,
they need a release so
that they're just tired
and they go to sleep
when they come home.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So
that's what-- when
we started doing more and
more of that, I continued.
Drew kind of moved
away from that
and started getting
obsessed with basketball.
He was obsessed--
DREW SCOTT: Let me just
point out one thing.
This is what I said.
Jonathan, you're going to
live a life as a magician
and never have a
date in your life.
If you ever want to
meet a girl, you're
not going to meet them at
your little nerdy clubs
when you get together
with other magicians.
JONATHAN SCOTT: However--
DREW SCOTT: Then--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Then we
would be at, like, a party,
and I had this circle of
girls around me in high school
doing magic, and
Drew would be, like,
dribbling a basketball
by himself in the corner.
DREW SCOTT: Look what I can do.
JONATHAN SCOTT: But, anyway.
So, anyway, yeah.
So the magic-- I
started doing that.
And also, like, doing
the clowning and stuff,
I didn't like putting on all
the makeup and everything.
So I stopped doing
drag, as well,
and then I just decided
magic was the way to go.
So I wanted to be, like,
the next David Copperfield.
And I'd won all these
awards performing
and did big, big,
Vegas-style shows.
DREW SCOTT: He was
ranked third-best--
JONATHAN SCOTT: I'll do it.
Here, I'll do something
right now, actually.
Everybody-- if I
can see your hands.
It's bright up here, but if
everyone puts their hands up,
like this, so I
can see your hands.
All right.
And this is a tricky one.
You do it, as well.
So now put your thumbs
down, like this,
and reach over-- so
right hand over left,
interlinking your thumbs--
and make sure that your-- no,
your right-hand pinkie
is over top, on the top.
So just watch closely.
And then, just go like
this with your thumbs,
and just put your thumbs up.
ALAN SEALES: What?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Give that a try.
ALAN SEALES: I can't--
DREW SCOTT: That's weird.
JONATHAN SCOTT: But if I had
a picture of what you all look
like, right now.
DREW SCOTT: Witch!
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
So, anyway, no.
It's just fun stuff.
But I used to do, like,
the big Vegas show.
ALAN SEALES: I'm going to
run this video in slow-mo
to figure out how to do that.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So
we just had fun.
And so whatever it was,
performing, entertaining,
we were always outgoing.
DREW SCOTT: You know what
he's never done, though.
You're a magician, and you
have an identical twin brother.
He's never used me in a trick.
Duh.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Maybe this
is the ultimate illusion.
ALAN SEALES: I was going
to ask if you had ever
done that dating,
but, obviously, not.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well, we--
DREW SCOTT: Well, we done that.
Ask my girlfriend.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Yeah, we did have--
we dated identical twin girls
in high school, which got really
creepy.
Because they were,
like, identical.
And then the four of us would
always be like, oh, wait.
Are you?
DREW SCOTT: Who am I with?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Who am I?
Are we going?
Did we just?
Oh, never mind.
So, it got too confusing,
so we broke up.
DREW SCOTT: But actually,
and that's the thing, too.
In "Dream Home," it's
not just about the buying
and selling and everything.
We tell a bit of our story--
where things started,
where things came from.
Because the reason a lot
of people enjoy the shows,
we don't take ourselves
very seriously.
We have fun when
we do the shows.
And we're trying to portray
that, as well, in here.
Because, our whole life,
we've been laughing.
On set, when we're
filming, I don't
know how we get any work done.
We spend all day laughing
with our crew and goofing off,
but we somehow still
manage to still--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Has everybody
seen "Property Brothers"
before?
Have you ever watched the show?
Oh, thank you.
DREW SCOTT: Who has
no idea who we are?
Put up-- show of hands.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Over there.
DREW SCOTT: Get out.
Green shirt-- green shirt, out.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So we
laugh, because-- so,
the homeowners come
on, and the homeowners,
they're generally
great-- generally.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, generally.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
But there's, like,
this one moment in time, where
every single homeowner-- and we
don't tell them to say anything.
We don't instruct them.
We don't want to say this and--
we just film them as they are.
And some of them, they
come out, at first,
and they're very stilted,
and they're like, oh, yes.
I love this house.
And we're like,
what are you doing?
Stop it.
Just be yourself.
DREW SCOTT: Be normal.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And I--
DREW SCOTT: They're trying
to portray what they
think they should be on TV.
ALAN SEALES: They're acting.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
Definitely.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And then
I'll say, be yourself.
There's no script.
And then, I'll say to them, I'm
like, you know, here's a house.
Here's what we
could possibly do.
And every single one of
them is always like, pfft,
you can't do that.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, I'm going
to give you an example of--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Have you not
watched the frigging show?
What the hell is wrong with you?
DREW SCOTT: Jonathan
quietly nods.
And if you watch
on the show, you'll
see he has a vein
on his forehead,
and it'll throb when he wants to
just throat-punch a homeowner.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I
have never wanted
to throat-punch a homeowner.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Once.
DREW SCOTT: Anyway, but most
of the homeowners are great.
I mean, it's a lot
of information.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I can't see him.
DREW SCOTT: This is our time.
JONATHAN SCOTT: OK.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, it's a
lot of information, obvi--
JONATHAN SCOTT: I'm
feeling left out.
DREW SCOTT: If you're buying,
selling, or renovating,
it's a big stressful area.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So what's
happening, over here?
DREW SCOTT: Anyway.
ALAN SEALES: What
about the schedule?
Because you talk about, you
have a very tight schedule
per episode, right?
Is it eight weeks?
Or so?
So it depends on the show--
JONATHAN SCOTT: First of
all, I'd like to point out,
you should never start
a conversation going,
you have a very tight, tight--
ALAN SEALES: Schedule.
Schedule.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Glutes.
DREW SCOTT: You noticed?
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Yeah, the schedule.
Yeah, it's back to back.
So we shoot four shows.
So we're nonstop all the time.
So we're just starting up
here in New York again.
We're going to be doing
mostly Westchester
and surrounding area.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Actually, all the way
from the Bronx, right
up to Connecticut.
ALAN SEALES: Listen, I applied
for this upcoming season,
thank you, very much.
And I got no call back.
DREW SCOTT: Aw.
Where were you looking?
ALAN SEALES:
Looking in Brooklyn.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I'll tell you.
There is a secret to
applying to the show.
You have to have
a different story.
So it's always, like-- they
get a lot of people who apply.
So I don't know what the story
is, but some people, they'll
go in and the application's
pretty straightforward.
They look for the applications
where you're like,
all this info, and, oh, I'm--
are you a secret acrobat,
or something?
I don't know.
The whatever it is.
They like people that
have a different story.
ALAN SEALES: No secret now.
DREW SCOTT: But
that's the thing.
Some people who
just submit, saying,
I'm looking to buy a house.
Let me know if I
can be on the show.
Well, they want
to see your story.
They want to see,
like, a family--
JONATHAN SCOTT: They're like,
we don't want that asshole.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Anyway,
the schedule.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yes.
Yes, but it's-- the schedule
is out of control sometimes,
but we enjoy it.
Because, you know, especially
when we do face-to-face stuff.
I love answering questions
live and finding out
what our fans enjoy.
And also through
social media, that's
a great way for us to connect.
We're the show-- the
one benefit of us
doing nonstop shows-- ten and
a half months of the year,
we film-- is that we will take
feedback through social media,
daily.
And so we have a whole team
that monitors the feedback
and takes the feedback.
And we will implement that
into our shows, the next day.
So, instead of a
lot of shows where
they wait until the
end of a season--
they'll do an analy--
oh, OK, we analyzed this.
This is what the change
will be for next season.
We literally are constantly
evolving the show.
So if somebody messages
through social media and says,
I really want to
see an apartment,
or I really want to see this and
that, we get it into the show.
DREW SCOTT: Mm-hm.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
DREW SCOTT: Doesn't mean we're
going to come down and do
Manhattan apartments, yet.
Logistically, that would be
a nightmare for production.
But maybe one day.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
I don't know.
Like, it so restrictive here.
And the co-ops and stuff
here, it's like impossible.
I've done a couple for the show.
I did a one that we had a
co-op that we had to deal with.
Oh, my gosh.
They'd given me the
wrong information.
I'd submit.
They'd given me the
wrong information,
so I'd have to resubmit.
But they're not meeting
for another month,
so I have to wait another
month before I resubmit,
because of their mistake.
So it's very difficult
to do Manhattan.
DREW SCOTT: It's
the cold shoulder.
It's the same in
his dating life.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
You'll notice 90% of the humor
usually is at my expense--
DREW SCOTT: Dating
expense, yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
--or my dating life.
ALAN SEALES: That's what
good brothers should
do for each other, right?
Um, actually, I should
get to my questions.
We've just been--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Eh,
questions, shmestions.
ALAN SEALES: So, OK.
Childhood.
Your first job-- I thought your
first job was painting fences,
but apparently it was
clowning around, literally.
DREW SCOTT: No, it
wasn't even clowning.
We had a job before that,
which he passed over.
So our very first
job aside from-- we
worked-- we grew up
on a ranch, so yeah.
Painting and stuff we had
to do around the house.
But our first job was we made
these decorative hangers.
We would weave nylon
around these hangers.
Because that was when my
dad said to us, get a job.
You're seven years old.
And so, we were making
the little nylon hangers
with a little rosette.
It's like an arts
and crafts thing.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Yeah, have you ever
been in your grandma's
closet, and she
had those nylon hangers?
We made those.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
It was cute.
And people thought, oh,
just two kids doing that.
But we actually were go-getters.
We were going to the neighbors.
We were finding people
to sell them to.
And we hooked up
with this lady who
had a chain of American
paraphernalia stores in Japan.
She started buying
them by the thousands.
ALAN SEALES: When
you were seven?
DREW SCOTT: We're
seven years old.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yep.
DREW SCOTT: So we started
hiring our older brother.
JONATHAN SCOTT: We're watching
cartoons with hangers,
and were weaving hangers, hiring
our friends and everything.
That was our very
first business.
And I even remember--
and this all
sounds like we're so
full of it, but-- we
have the most
bizarre-- We should
be like 90 for the amount
of stuff that we've done.
But I remember that
at seven years old
we went over to Scotland
to visit our family.
And my parents'
credit cards had all
been cut off, because the
bank thought, oh, fraud.
Something's going on.
So my parents had to have
us, as the seven-year-olds,
float them for three days until
the new cards were delivered,
because our little
hanger business.
DREW SCOTT: So Jonathan was just
out there, at seven, balling.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Popping juice bottles.
Making it rain.
ALAN SEALES: That's right.
That's right.
So then, fast forward
a little bit, and you
guys grow up a little.
So--
DREW SCOTT: Not much.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Not much, though.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
you get taller.
So at what point did one of you
decide to be the contractor,
and one was the Realtor?
And did you ever, like,
consider any other combinations?
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Well, most people
don't realize that Drew used to
do all the work with me, back
in the day.
When we first started,
while we were in college,
he would get in.
He would do flooring, siding,
everything with me, no problem.
And then, like, 1996, he
broke a nail, and it was done.
No more after that.
DREW SCOTT: These were
made to be innocent.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
No, the funny thing
was-- so when we
started the property
business-- we've been doing--
we started our real estate
company.
We had a lot of investments.
We were doing this
for, like, 10 years
before we were approached.
And then, originally,
the network
asked for Drew to be the
contractor, because he
looked more rugged
and-- Drew used
to look like a homeless person.
DREW SCOTT: I used
to do the renos.
JONATHAN SCOTT: It
was just all shaggy.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, we had
the same longer hair.
If you remember season
1 Jonathan hair,
like that lioness mane.
It was terrible.
I had long hair, as well.
JONATHAN SCOTT: We were awesome.
DREW SCOTT: And so they
thought I looked more brawny.
And he was the broker for
our real estate company
at the time.
So he had more real
estate designation than me
at the time.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
DREW SCOTT: And so
they thought, you
can be the rugged hands-on guy.
You can be the whatever.
And I was like--
ALAN SEALES: The whatever.
DREW SCOTT: --this sucks.
Because I did not want
to be doing the dirty
renos every single day.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So
we were actually
flying in to do the
test shoot for the show,
and, on our way
there, I was bragging.
I was like, I'm going to
have, like, Armani suits
and you name it.
And then, they found
out that I'm actually
a licensed contractor,
and he is not.
And they were like, well, then
that could go terribly wrong.
So they switched it.
Which, in reality, it could
not have worked the other way.
So we switched it.
And then, when we got
there, Drew walks in,
and he's got all
these suits lined up,
and the wardrobe was amazing.
And the woman says to me,
like, what do you think?
Is there-- pull anything
that's in your wardrobe.
It was all Wal-Mart
denim and, like,
flannel-- the whole thing.
DREW SCOTT: It was flannel--
JONATHAN SCOTT: I was like--
DREW SCOTT: It was overalls,
flannel, and plaid.
That's all that was
in the wardrobes.
I'm like, suck it.
Can I have the Armani shoes?
ALAN SEALES: So you were
talking about the audition
and going to the network.
But how did you even
get to that point?
DREW SCOTT: So we
had been doing--
we got away from acting
and all that side of it.
And for about 10 years, right
out of high school-- 10 years,
our real estate
company had grown.
We had been doing pretty well.
ALAN SEALES: You were in
business as flippers-- house
flippers.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And we were
working with clients, too.
DREW SCOTT: We did
work with clients.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
A lot of clients.
DREW SCOTT: But the big
thing, at that point,
after the 10-year
mark, I realized acting
was my true passion, directing.
I want to do more of that.
And so I actually left
Calgary, where our company was,
and moved back to Vancouver
to pursue the creative side
of what I wanted to do.
The whole reason we
were doing real estate
was to fund that and whatever.
And so I started
doing a bit more
acting out there, auditioning.
But I started getting more
host auditions because
of my real estate
expertise, than I
was getting acting auditions.
So I never thought about it.
At first, Jonathan and
I were both like, well,
we don't want to be hosts.
That's lame.
We want to be actors,
because it's cool.
And then, now that we
look back, we're like,
it just makes so
much sense for us.
We're sort of doing-- it's
a blend of our two goals.
JONATHAN SCOTT: OK.
He is yada-yadaing the funniest
part of the whole story.
The first big gig that we
were-- or, he was offered,
rather-- was not
"Property Brothers."
The first show he was
pitched for as the host
was called "Realtor Idol."
It was "American
Idol" for Realtors.
DREW SCOTT: (SINGING)
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
JONATHAN SCOTT: It was the
dumbest idea I have ever heard.
And the show went no where.
DREW SCOTT: But I
have an awesome voice.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
The show went nowhere.
So then, after that,
the same producers
found out that he
had a brother that
was a designer a
contractor, and then
that's when they
approached us about doing
what we do with clients.
DREW SCOTT: So they
pitched us exactly what
we were doing with clients.
And, in the beginning, the funny
thing is HGTV turned it down.
At first, they had said, we
don't really see an appeal
with two brothers renovating.
No.
And then, HGTV Canada
turned it down.
It was a network
in Canada, called
W network, that said, OK.
We'll give it a shot.
And within three weeks, we went
to number one of the night.
And then, within a matter
of weeks after that,
we were number one
show on their network.
And they were blown away.
So then HGTV was
like, let's just
try a half-hour
cut-down version.
Same thing.
And then a few
months after that,
we've been top shows on the
HGTV for, like, six years.
Thanks to you guys who watch.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Job security--
DREW SCOTT: Not green shirt,
sweater, over there-- no her.
But, everyone else.
So thank you, you guys.
ALAN SEALES: So do you ever
film more than one episode
at a time?
Or is it--
DREW SCOTT: Always.
10 at a time.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
DREW SCOTT: We do
10 at a time, yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So
that's what I have.
Like, all day, I'm just
between three or four sites,
every single day.
DREW SCOTT: Those grays,
they were not there
before shooting 10
episodes at a time.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Drew's got
the best job in the world.
Because, once the
construction starts on
"Property Brothers--
Buying and Selling,"
he's not needed at that point.
So spas, golf-- if you've got
recommendations for panini
places.
DREW SCOTT: I love Winged Foot.
Just saying, here,
if anyone golfs.
JONATHAN SCOTT: But
then-- so that's
why I love "Brother
versus Brother."
Because when we're filming
"Brother versus Brother,"
I'm not helping him.
So he's got his own house.
He does his own design.
He gets in there and
does hands-on work.
So, obviously, it's comical.
But--
DREW SCOTT: Actually,
the funny thing
is-- we joke about all the time.
But because, when we
started "Property Brothers,"
we wanted to define the roles.
I think you brought
this up earlier.
We didn't want it just
to be a twin gimmick.
So, I actually cut
my hair shorter,
so we didn't look the same.
We defined our roles.
Even though Jonathan had
licensing as a real estate
agent, I used to do
the hands-on work.
That way, people aren't
confused who's who.
And when he's doing, he just
does dirtier work than I do.
We run multiple
companies together.
I get to keep a suit on
and stay clean, while I'm
doing all the other work.
So we work from
7:00 in the morning
until 10:00 at night, pretty
well every single day.
JONATHAN SCOTT: The
most annoying part
is that-- because we're
working together all the time,
we've got all these businesses
on the go-- then we go home,
and we're in bunk beds.
So it's just--
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, it's tough.
JONATHAN SCOTT: You can never
get separated from each other.
DREW SCOTT: I can
hear his texting.
ALAN SEALES: And your
feet's hanging off
the end of the bed, yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Exactly, right?
DREW SCOTT: His sexting
is so annoying, when it--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, so weird.
DREW SCOTT: Awkward.
ALAN SEALES: It's after 5:00 PM.
It's OK.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So, as the
viewer, in your episodes,
we only get to see a few rooms.
Do you do the whole house, too?
Or, is it just like--
DREW SCOTT: We leave them
to sleep on the ground.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
JONATHAN SCOTT: No,
they-- that's actually
probably the biggest question
we get-- what happens
to the other areas of the home?
So, we only have
time to film three
or four rooms for
"Property Brothers."
ALAN SEALES: For
JONATHAN SCOTT: So the
budget and the timelines
are only for three
or four rooms.
I'm not renovating an
entire house for $80,000.
We usually do renovate the
whole house, inside and out.
But that's a separate
timeline, separate budget.
And keep in mind, too, that
we work with local trades
in every city that we go to.
So, you know, I do the
design on all the properties.
And I jump in.
And the tighter the budget
gets, the more I do,
because I don't
charge for my time.
Drew charges triple.
So, you know, it all depends.
Every home is different.
Some of the houses, they
don't need anything else
done anywhere else.
Most of the houses, there's a
lot of work to do everywhere.
ALAN SEALES: Do they
keep the furniture?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yep.
On "Property Brothers."
DREW SCOTT: On "Property
Brothers," it's all built in.
I mean, Jonathan tries to reuse
some of their current pieces,
just refurbishing them.
But they keep it all.
On "Buying and Selling,"
typically, they don't.
Because we're staging
a house, so we're
just renting furniture to stage.
ALAN SEALES: When
you said reuse,
I thought-- I was
picturing that you
went into the last
house you just finished.
And you were like, let me
borrow this for a second,
I want to put it--
JONATHAN SCOTT: We're going
to throw all this stuff out.
Don't follow us.
ALAN SEALES: Don't worry.
Don't worry.
JONATHAN SCOTT: No, I laugh,
because I'll take-- on average,
I'll usually be able
to reuse about 50%
of a homeowner's existing stuff.
So, you know, they'll
come in for the reveal,
and they'll be like,
(HIGH-PITCHED VOICE) oh,
my gosh, I love it.
This is so fantastic.
Why does that look so familiar?
But I'll have
re-painted the table,
or I'll re-upholster
a couch, or something.
And they don't recognize it.
So, it goes to
show that you don't
have to throw everything out.
You can reuse tons of stuff.
DREW SCOTT: It adds
character to a design.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Right.
ALAN SEALES: So, shifting
back to the book, here.
DREW SCOTT: By the
way, can I say,
I love the fact that you've
already, like, ear-marked so
many pages, there.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, this was--
DREW SCOTT: That means you've
actually done some work.
ALAN SEALES: I read
the whole thing.
Yeah.
And, well, this is how I
put my questions together.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, thank you.
ALAN SEALES: So I just wrote
squiggly lines, and went back
and made things up--
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Because, until now,
we thought you were a fraud.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: I get that a lot.
JONATHAN SCOTT: [LAUGHS]
ALAN SEALES: So the book--
like I said, very easy to read.
I enjoyed the personal
stories as much
as the business
how-to's, I guess.
But you divided it up into
very specific sections.
Like, how did you come
up with those sections?
Because it's like, "How
to find a contractor,"
"How to do the design."
I particularly liked
the outdoor space,
because you don't get to
go into that in the show.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
Well, that's actually
one of our favorite areas
is outdoor, for
making over a space.
Even with QVC, when we
launched our outdoor furniture
and decor, the reason
we started outdoor
is because it's
our favorite space.
Now we're doing our indoor
collections, as well.
But it was tough.
Because we have so
much information.
From over the years, we
started mid- to late-90s.
And we've renovated,
we've bought, we've sold,
we've built new.
We've-- even if it's just
redesigning furniture,
designing the space to
maximize what you have,
even if you don't own.
We wanted to find ways to give
something-- everybody something
that they could take
out of the book.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And for it
to be an easy resource guide.
So that if I'm like, you know
what, I'm prepping my house
to sell-- boom, they go
straight to a chapter that says,
"Prepping my house to sell."
Or, if they're
just saying, I just
want to be inspired of what I
could do for the spring-- boom,
there's stuff on it.
So that was the
biggest thing for us.
I was actually amazed.
When we started researching,
that we wanted to write a book,
we wanted to research what
was already out there.
There was not one
single resource
for people that is
simple to inspire them
about what they should do,
what questions they should ask.
So we compiled all
of our knowledge
and researched even more stuff
that you haven't seen the show.
There's a lot-- I'd say,
three-quarters of the projects
and the photography
in this book are not
from houses you've
ever seen before.
They're other projects.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
There's lots of
pictures in here.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
And all of it was so it
was all in one place.
So you don't have to have 50
books trying to figure out
how to reno your place.
DREW SCOTT: You realize,
Jonathan's talking right now,
so no one's looking at you.
You're like, I want
to show you pictures.
And all the women in the crowd
are just like, (DREAMY VOICE)
what's Jonathan saying?
JONATHAN SCOTT: I wish.
DREW SCOTT: Sigh.
No-- we're going get--
ALAN SEALES: He gives
you compliments,
but you are identical.
I just want to point that out.
JONATHAN SCOTT: We
have the same face.
ALAN SEALES: Yes, yes.
DREW SCOTT: He has fancier hair.
DREW SCOTT: We're identical.
He has fancier hair.
He's had more dust in
construction sites,
so this is now.
This is four years from now.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
Anyway.
Sawdust-- actually,
it's not sawdust.
I call it man glitter.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Man glitter is
really rough on the complexion.
DREW SCOTT: No, but it--
that's really, honestly,
one of the things we
wanted there for the book
was to make sure that there
was a ton of information,
it was easy, accessible, a lot
of lists, and a lot of charts.
Even charts to
help you if you're
looking at getting products
for your house-- appliances,
flooring, outdoor
furniture, whatever it is.
We're also listing
off what time of year
you'll get the best deals
from the different retailers.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah.
That was helpful.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, super helpful.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah,
the deals calendar.
Yeah.
There's even actual
floor plans that
are common problems we find
a lot of clients bring,
so that you can see the
solution to that floor plan.
So.
ALAN SEALES: Something
earlier you said,
what was the section
that jumped out to me--
there was something else that
I thought, when I read it,
I was like, oh, yeah, that
makes sense was you saying,
list your house lower than
you want to get money.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: List your house
lower than you want someone
to make an offer for.
DREW SCOTT: So, well, yeah.
The whole strategy
here-- and we've
done this for many, many years--
is, if you think about it,
if you have, say, three
houses in your neighborhood
that are pretty comparable.
And you price yours really high,
you're going to sell a house.
It may not be yours,
but you're making
the other houses look better.
So what we've always done--
because, if you think
about it, if all the
houses are pretty similar,
but you're the top priced
one, well, then, obviously,
they'll say, why
would I pay more?
I'll go to the more
inexpensive one.
So what we always do is we make
our houses the nicer house, out
of all the comparable
properties.
We have them staged beautifully.
Buyers can see the
way they want to live.
Yet, we price it just
under-- maybe 5% under market
value-- then, all
of a sudden, you
have all these other
houses that are blah.
Your house just under
that price that's amazing.
Everyone gets in a frenzy.
And we also delay our offer
acceptance, about a week.
I usually will list
on a Wednesday,
and then I'll accept
offers on a Sunday.
People get in a frenzy
for about a week,
and then they all of
a sudden bring offers.
And we always end up
getting a higher bid.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Every
strategy is different.
And you look at
the neighborhoods,
and you look at the
community and the demand.
But one of the things people ask
is like, I'll do an open house,
and that will really sell it.
But, you know, I would say that
maybe less than 5% of our sales
have ever happened
from open houses.
Open houses are actually just a
way for your real estate agent
to meet more clients.
That's actually what it is.
So, unless you have
something very specific
that you need people to
see inside the house that
will sell them on the house,
that they wouldn't know
from looking on the
outside, there's
not a huge value
on the open house.
So we always say, don't make
that your only-- you know,
some people will
say, well, I'm just
going to try the market
at a really high price,
and maybe there'll be
that one, you know,
dumb buyer right there
who's willing to pay.
That's not how it works.
You get-- it's like
your first date.
You get one crack at
a first impression.
And the challenge, too,
is, if you list high,
and then you chase
the market down
as we go into the
fall and the winter
when less people
are looking, what
you could have got at a
higher price in the spring,
you will not get
in the wintertime.
So there's a lot of strategy.
Most people think it's very
simple to sell a house,
so I can do it myself.
There's actually
a lot of strategy
involved in trying to sell
it, and get the top dollar.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: You were
saying, too, the little bit
of behind the scenes, you
also talk about in the book
is with the MLS system--
which, I don't even
know how much that
applies in New York.
It's all a big mess here.
That you only get to
be a new house, once.
DREW SCOTT: Well,
that's really it.
I mean, what you'll see
a lot of agents will do
is they'll list a
house really high,
they'll sit it on
the market for a bit,
and then they'll start
to bring price down.
Others will list it high.
They'll take it off the
market, and then they'll
re-list it as a new
listing at a lower price
to try and get that initial
pop, because that will show up.
People-- when you're on the
MLS, what a lot of people do
is they select what
they want to see.
If a house is listed without
photos, 99% of buyers
don't want to see a
house without photos.
So even if it's the
most beautiful house
at a great price, they
won't even look at it.
They'll skip over it.
And even if you add photos
later, a lot of times
they'll check not to
bother looking at that.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And
that's something
that's very hard for
people to understand.
It's an auto-mail-out,
an auto-email,
that happens when you're
a buyer on the MLS.
You set your
criteria, and as soon
as something comes on the
market that fits your criteria,
it auto-emails it to you.
But, yeah.
Most buyers, they
won't look at it
if it doesn't have a picture.
So if your agent ever
says, well, we'll
just get the
listing up, and then
when the photos are done in a
couple days, we'll load them.
No.
Do not do it.
DREW SCOTT: Or even if
you're reducing the price
a week or two down
the road, a lot
of times people will check off
they don't care about that.
They want to see
only fresh listings.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Right.
So, if anybody has any
questions for them,
there are two mics
in the aisles, here.
They can-- anything
is fair game?
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Anything is fair game,
and we can hear you
wherever you are right.
ALAN SEALES: Well--
DREW SCOTT: Oh, here it is.
ALAN SEALES: It's being
recorded, so we need to.
So, while people are
lining up, I actually
want to get you guys going
here with some white boards.
We're going to play a version
of the "Newlywed Game."
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, gosh.
DREW SCOTT: We suck at this.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I will point
out, we are the worst at this.
ALAN SEALES: We'll call it
the Drewlywed Game or the--
JONATHAN SCOTT: You
would think that we
would be able to read
each other's minds.
ALAN SEALES: --the
Twinlywed Game?
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, there we go.
ALAN SEALES: OK.
So, we'll do some
easy ones, here.
So, in terms of
property value, what's
the worst thing someone
can do to their house
when renovating to sell?
JONATHAN SCOTT: All right.
Um.
DREW SCOTT: All right.
JONATHAN SCOTT: All right.
ALAN SEALES: One, two, three.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Add a pool.
DREW SCOTT: Yep.
ALAN SEALES: Very good.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Ha!
DREW SCOTT: I mean, a pool
is great, if you love a pool.
But, if you put in a pool
today, and try and sell
it tomorrow-- like you're
putting it as a feature--
you'll never make
the money back.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So, what's the
worst thing you've seen?
Is it just a pool, or has
there been something, like, so
over the top that it sticks out?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well, no.
One of things--
I can't stand it.
And there have been
clients-- there
are a lot of clients we
wouldn't take on if they weren't
willing to work by our rules.
One is, you disclose
everything, and you're
honest about everything.
We would have clients--
they'd be like, (GRUFF VOICE)
well, so we may have had a mold
problem, but I painted over it,
and it's hidden.
And I moved a piece of furniture
in front of the bad part.
And that's good.
DREW SCOTT: Or they'll dry
wall over foundation cracks
and stuff.
I even had-- I worked
up in Vancouver
as an agent for a long
time-- and in Vancouver, it's
like the North American capital
for grow ops in everyone's
basement and stuff.
ALAN SEALES:
(LAUGHING) Oh, right.
DREW SCOTT: In this
one house, this guy
asked me to come and check
out his house to list it.
And he had a door
locked in the basement.
And I saw signs
like the-- that you
see for that sort of a thing.
He wouldn't open the door.
He said, oh, I
just lost the key.
That was where his grow op
was, and which I found out.
I'm like, I'm not
listing your house,
and I've reported your house.
ALAN SEALES: Which,
by the way, I
was looking back to
fact-check the magician thing.
And "magician" is not in
your book's index, but--
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Is "illusionist"?
Did you look at "illusionist"?
ALAN SEALES: No,
magician is not in there,
but grow op--
"marijuana grow op" is.
DREW SCOTT: There you go.
JONATHAN SCOTT: It is in there.
DREW SCOTT: That's my magic.
ALAN SEALES: So what we'll do--
DREW SCOTT: Great
supplemental income-- oh, no.
Never mind.
I never said that.
ALAN SEALES: We'll
do one more question,
and then we'll take
an audience question.
All right.
So, here.
Jonathan's dream home
number-one must-have feature is?
JONATHAN SCOTT: My
feature in the dream home?
DREW SCOTT: In his dream home?
ALAN SEALES: Yes, yes.
JONATHAN SCOTT: All right.
ALAN SEALES: All right, ready?
JONATHAN SCOTT: I write
like a five-year-old
with a broken hand, by the way.
ALAN SEALES: One, two, three.
JONATHAN SCOTT: What is it?
ALAN SEALES: Aw.
DREW SCOTT: Space for your dogs?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, water slide.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, you big jerk.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I shove my
dogs down the water slide.
DREW SCOTT: You jerk.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I
do have two dogs.
So, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Question over here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hi, guys.
I'm from Toronto originally.
JONATHAN SCOTT: All right.
AUDIENCE: And I love going
back to the first season
and watching just for
the nostalgia value.
DREW SCOTT: Just
to hear, "Toronah."
Or to hear the--
JONATHAN SCOTT: A lot more
people are like, "Oh, sori,
I'd really like to see
aboot the new designs."
DREW SCOTT: The new hoos.
That's a new hoos.
AUDIENCE: Well, so,
actually I was wondering,
what do you find is
the biggest difference
between working in Canada
and working in the States?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh.
Oh, I will tell you.
So.
DREW SCOTT: Wait.
Hold up.
What's the one stereotype that
you all think about Canadians?
AUDIENCE: Polite.
JONATHAN SCOTT: They're
so polite, right?
DREW SCOTT: Not on this show.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So we will
be filming in Toronto--
so we film usually-- because
the production company that
does "Property Brothers" is
based out of Toronto-- so we
usually do, like, every second
or third season up in Toronto
for a few months.
Anyway, so, we'll do a house.
And we'll say to the
homeowners, like, oh, we're
doing all this work on
your house and everything.
Maybe we could film with you
on, say, Tuesday and Friday
at 2:00 o'clock.
And they'll be like, nah.
And we're like, oh, well, we're
giving you $10,000 and $40,000
in free stuff, and it would
be great if we could-- Nah.
But if we're filming in the
States, they're like, oh, yeah.
I'll quit my job.
I'll pull my kids out of school.
No problem, everything,
whatever you want.
DREW SCOTT: I think it's
less about the polite side,
and it's more about in
the US they'll do anything
to be on TV, kind of thing.
Anyways, it is fun, though.
We love mixing it up
between cities across the US
and across Canada.
And we do-- we're going up to
Toronto again later this year.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
I work in sales at Google.
And one of my favorite
parts of the show,
I think is really
underrated, is--
it always typically
happens like this--
go to see a house, right?
And they go, oh, it's
listed at, like, $560,000,
and then Drew come in.
And he goes, well, I think the
market value's about $520,000.
And the next thing you know,
you put in the offer, you
get it at $520,000.
And it, like, always happens.
So what I'd like
to really know is--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Miracle worker.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm giving you a big
compliment, here, but-- one,
how do you know the markets?
And you go to all
these different places.
And then, two, just
giving a context
on how you actually go through
the negotiation process.
DREW SCOTT: So--
ALAN SEALES: And look at how our
sales guy dresses, by the way.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah,
and you know what?
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JONATHAN SCOTT: Sale are
rough these days, huh?
Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: Actually,
I love the question,
because one thing that annoys
me a little bit-- there's
so much information that
we could show on our shows,
but we only have 42 minutes
with commercials and everything.
We only have 42 minutes
to tell a story.
And so, I don't always--
like, if a house
is-- if the value of the
home is $520,000, well,
obviously, I go in a
little bit lower than that,
unless I just want to
make a hard sale and say,
this is as high as
we're going, we're
going to come in at top price.
But sometimes we
don't get to show
all of the back and
forth and everything.
We work with a team of
local agents, as well.
It's pretty easy
for me to figure out
market value on a
place, just because I've
been doing this for so long.
But I still always have
a team of local agents
who also work with
me, because they've
been working that market.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And
it's the same with me
on the construction side.
I don't know the local
amendments to the code.
Every city has local amendments
the National Building Code.
And so, I have local trades,
and we come about three months
ahead of time to start
finding real estate agents,
find trades who set the
bar high like we do.
And the other big thing, too,
is, when I finish a renovation,
and I leave, I
want there to still
be a warranty on all
the work for the people
that I'm leaving behind.
So we make sure that we work
with local GCs, as well,
who provide the warranty
on everything that happens.
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
JONATHAN SCOTT: We create about
100 local jobs in every city
that we go to.
So it's nice to be able
to surge into the--
DREW SCOTT: Beat that, Google.
Oh, wait.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I
thought your question was
going to be, like-- because
everyone's always like, oh,
you know the part where
you, like, show them
the perfect house, and you're
like, ha, you can't afford it!
I hate that part of the show.
DREW SCOTT: I love it.
Love it.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
The nice thing is
it's getting hard
now to do that,
because most people
have seen the show.
But, when that
happens, you'll be
amazed how people, like, paint
this picture-- even if they've
been looking for two years
in a space, they're like,
oh, Drew found the
perfect spot I can afford.
DREW SCOTT: They
literally think I've
found that magical
one property that
fits their budget, when
they've been searching
that neighborhood for years.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
JONATHAN SCOTT: He's got
the most maniacal laugh
when that happens.
DREW SCOTT: I have this
hairless cat that I pull out,
and I just pet it. [EVIL LAUGH]
ALAN SEALES: All right.
So we'll do the flip
of the other question.
DREW SCOTT: Oh.
ALAN SEALES: Drew's dream home
number-one must-have feature
is?
DREW SCOTT: [LAUGHS] I don't
know if he'll get this.
But--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Mm-hm.
DREW SCOTT: My girlfriend.
ALAN SEALES: Aw.
JONATHAN SCOTT: [GAGGING SOUND]
DREW SCOTT: All right.
That's not what I'm
putting on here.
All right.
JONATHAN SCOTT: OK.
ALAN SEALES: He's still writing.
DREW SCOTT: OK.
ALAN SEALES: Ready?
And go.
DREW SCOTT: Huge closet.
ALAN SEALES: Oh.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Gigantic closet.
ALAN SEALES: There you go.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I would
like to point out-- so, who
saw "Property Brothers
at Home," when
we renovated our home in Vegas?
AUDIENCE: Woo!
Woo!
JONATHAN SCOTT: So we got all
the cool stuff-- the water
slide and stuff like that.
No sooner did we finish
that renovation--
so it was, like, June of
last year-- we finished it,
and it was a huge,
biggest residential reno
I've ever done.
It was so much.
It was so exhausting.
Literally, two days when
we're done, Drew comes out
of his room-- because we
sold our individual places
and got one big, kind of
compound, there in Vegas--
and comes out and
he's like, I want
you to rip the
back of the garage
out and give me a bigger closet.
And so, I had to sa-- so he
now has 180 pairs of shoes.
DREW SCOTT: He added--
JONATHAN SCOTT: I'm not kidding.
DREW SCOTT: He added
17 feet onto my closet.
I took it from the
back of the garage.
JONATHAN SCOTT: All shoe racks.
ALAN SEALES: That's the size
of some people's apartment
in New York.
DREW SCOTT: Yes.
Yes.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I'm
not kidding you.
It is.
His closet is ridiculous.
DREW SCOTT: I like
my men's fashion.
And some of it is
ladies fashion.
That's for Linda, not for me.
ALAN SEALES: Question.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
So that rings true for me.
I just closed on my first
apartment on Friday.
DREW SCOTT: Congratulations.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yay.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
After 100 open
houses, so feel lucky
that you weren't a part of that.
But I'm leaving from here to
go meet my general contractor.
And that raises two questions.
First, floor color--
what's your go-to.
What do you pick?
And, two, given the limited
space we have in New York City,
would you recommend ripping out
a bathtub for a shower, if you
don't plan to put kids in
there, and it's smaller, so.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well, we only
have time for 40 questions.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: I'll just--
DREW SCOTT: One
thing I want to say
is, I feel sorry for your
agent taking you to--
AUDIENCE: I did it alone.
DREW SCOTT: Oh,
you did it alone.
OK.
Hoo!
100 open houses.
Anyway--
AUDIENCE: That's
why it took so long.
DREW SCOTT: Don't say
to your contractor,
Jonathan can do it for $50,000.
Can you do it?
They hate that.
If you only have one
ba-- is it one bathroom?
AUDIENCE: It's one
full bath, one half.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, so.
Oh, one full and one half.
So, the one thing
that's a little tricky--
you know, condo
living is different,
because it's not as
much a family thing--
but what I always
say, if you only
had one bathroom in the house
with a tub, don't take it out.
Because now you're
eliminating any families
that would look at it.
However, when you're
here in Manhattan,
it's a little bit different.
Your typical market
is not just family.
So you may be OK.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Are you planning
to have children and keep
this condo?
AUDIENCE: No, not keep it.
It's a condo.
We'll hold on to
it, but we'll never.
JONATHAN SCOTT: OK, yeah.
Because that's the big thing.
Buyers, even though they know
they could just renovate it
back, they never do.
They'll just wash their hands
and move on to something.
Because, if you have
kids, you need a bathtub.
ALAN SEALES: There's
a whole section
in the book about
renovating to sell.
DREW SCOTT: Yes.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Yeah, well, exactly.
ALAN SEALES: Yes, yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And
we had one client
who fought me tooth and nail.
And she was like, no, I'll
teach my kids to shower.
Her kids were like two--
DREW SCOTT: Two, yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: --and one.
I was like, what the hell
are you talking about?
I'm picturing this one-foot
tall kid-- yeah, all right.
Breastfeed me.
So, anyway, that was
the first question.
What was your other question?
Oh, flooring.
AUDIENCE: Flooring.
JONATHAN SCOTT: So, I
love a mid-tone wood,
like a beautiful
hand-scraped look.
The nice thing
about hand-scraped
is it will mask any scratches
that you get on there,
or if you have a dog
that sheds hair, as well.
Having a mid-tone is
a lot easier to hide,
because dark floors
show everything.
And light, light
floors show everything.
So mid-tone is great.
But also, depending on yourself,
if you have a dog that's
going to trash or
if you've got, like,
three kids, two dogs,
and four husbands,
you want to make sure you'll
have flooring that will last.
So you can do vinyl
plank flooring.
It is indistinguishable
from hard wood.
I even fooled Drew.
He went down and felt it, and
he thought it was hardwood,
and it wasn't.
It was vinyl plank flooring.
DREW SCOTT: Tricks
me all the time.
Or plank style in
your kitchen space,
or a porcelain-- plank
style porcelain also works.
It's more durable than
a regular hardwood.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well, we're
out of time for everybody else.
So, um.
Yeah.
Congrats on the new house.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
Whiteboard question, here.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, whiteboard.
DREW SCOTT: All right.
ALAN SEALES: If Jonathan had to
pick a new profession, nothing
that he has ever done before--
DREW SCOTT: Nothing?
ALAN SEALES: --he would be a?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh,
so not a magician.
OK.
ALAN SEALES: Yes,
not a magician, not
a water slide connoisseur.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Huh.
Let's see here.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, wait.
JONATHAN SCOTT: How can you
answer this question faster
than I can.
DREW SCOTT: I was going
to say a smart ass,
but he does that all the time.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well, I'll tell
you what I always wanted to be,
and I never--
DREW SCOTT: Let's see.
Hold on.
This is probably not it.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
JONATHAN SCOTT: When
I was five years old
and got up in
front of the class,
and everyone was
telling the teacher,
you know, oh, I want
to be a policeman,
and I want to be a fireman.
I got up in front of
everyone and said,
I want to be a flower man.
I don't even know
what the hell that is.
DREW SCOTT: Party planner.
ALAN SEALES: What
would a flower man do?
DREW SCOTT: It's like a florist.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I don't know.
DREW SCOTT: But he thought
it was called a flower man.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I remember as
a kid, my dad would walk me,
like when it was Mother's Day
or whatever, he would walk in,
take me with him to the
floral shop kind of a thing.
And I always just thought,
they must love working in here.
It smells so good.
And I wanted to be a flower man.
ALAN SEALES: Question.
AUDIENCE: So, like Alan, I
also applied for this season.
And I got a very fast response--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh, ouch.
ALAN SEALES: Oh.
AUDIENCE: --thanking me for
my fantastic application.
But the one stipulation
for this season
is that I was responsible
for finding the property.
And so my husband and
I did consider it,
and we did it a
pretty big search.
But we kept coming
back to the fact
that we were a little concerned
about finding this property,
not knowing if it was really
a good-- had good bones,
or if it was really a tear down.
So we would love your
advice, because we
will continue to search.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
So that's-- so when we first
started "Property Brothers"--
so now we're everything
in three-month blocks,
where we come in and we shoot
all of the shows in three
months when we go.
We first started
"Property Brothers,"
we started with people before
they had even started looking.
They didn't know
what they wanted.
They hadn't put any offers in.
They hadn't done anything.
And it was taking so long, and
a lot of them would get outbid,
and everything going on.
So we opened it up to people
who had already been searching
and who mostly have identified
a house that they like.
We still show them other houses.
And, rarely, will they actually
switch and go to another house.
Most of the time, it's
the house that they
have found that they love.
I can renovate any home,
absolutely any home,
and I can make it beautiful.
But you're right.
We had one client, who, against
every piece of information
I gave him and everything that--
oh, the other thing, too is,
you'll be working with a
Realtor, your own Realtor,
when-- I always laugh, because,
when we come into the picture,
your Realtor is always
like, can I at least
get a-- can I get a
referral fee or something?
And we're like, we don't take
you away from your Realtor.
We work with your
Realtor to make sure
that everything comes together.
DREW SCOTT: At the
end of the day,
I mean, the main thing for
us is we work with locals.
Whether you're already
with them, or we
introduce you to other agents.
Because outside
of us filming-- we
do up to 10 episodes at a time.
I can't be out there showing
every single property.
Jonathan can't be out there
on every single property.
So we have real estate
agents working under me.
We have construction
leads, design leads,
that work under us.
The big thing would
be-- it's getting
you closer to that
point where you're
ready to pull the trigger.
JONATHAN SCOTT: And one of the
conditions you should always
have, if you're doing a
major, major reno on a place,
is that you have a contractor
come in and price out the work
and see.
So usually, I recommend
getting a couple in.
They don't charge for a quote.
They'll come, and they'll
look at everything,
and tell you what they think.
If you see that the
numbers are way more
than what you thought
it was going to be,
you can walk away from the deal
without losing your deposit,
and that's that.
That's the challenge
with me, though,
to come in as the designer.
A lot of times, I
won't even meet you
until you've already
narrowed down your search
and you've done all that.
So that's why you want to
have somebody that you know
has got you in the ballpark.
I know I can make a house
beautiful, absolutely.
And I get you all kinds of
free stuff, which is nice.
DREW SCOTT: And I also know
that he'll never stop talking.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I
never stopped talking.
Yeah.
So, anyway.
That'd be cool.
DREW SCOTT: Good luck
with the house hunt.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
They still haven't
fully-- I think there's, like,
four families left that they
haven't finished casting yet.
But like I was saying earlier,
find something unique,
if you stay in touch with them.
Because we've had it before
where people were told,
no, and then all of
a sudden something
happened, and it worked.
Everything lined up.
AUDIENCE: I know.
That's perfect.
We're still in the
consideration set.
We just have to find the
property, so we're excited.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Nice.
Very exciting.
DREW SCOTT: Good
luck, good luck.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
So, the flip of the question--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Sucker.
Oh.
ALAN SEALES: Listen, my story
is that I've interviewed you.
Does that not count
for something?
DREW SCOTT: No,
they're like, hell, no.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
So if Drew had to pick a
new profession, nothing
you've already done
so far, he would be a?
Oh, one of you is left-handed,
the other one isn't?
DREW SCOTT: I can go both ways.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
I'm more creative.
DREW SCOTT: Whoa, whoa.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Hey.
Are we talking about writing?
ALAN SEALES: I work here.
I can't say that.
All right.
Ready?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Ready?
ALAN SEALES: One, two, three.
Spa analyst?
DREW SCOTT: What?
JONATHAN SCOTT: A spa analyst,
because he spends half his life
at a spa.
What did you put?
DREW SCOTT: Pro golfer.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
He would totally want
to be a pro golfer.
DREW SCOTT: Spa analyst?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Here's a
little tidbit of information.
So Drew is so
frigging competitive.
He takes lessons for everything.
So he take golf
lessons, guitar lessons,
like-- he's taking
ping pong less--
he's been taking ping
pong lessons for two years
from a ping pong master,
so he can beat me.
That's--
DREW SCOTT: Has anybody
here been to Spin?
Anybody here been to
Spin, the ping pong bar?
Isn't it awesome?
Wouldn't you like
to just go in there
and crush those guys
that are in there?
Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Because wouldn't
that get you so far in life?
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
Totally.
JONATHAN SCOTT: He does.
So when we did our
cruise-- our fan cruise
in the fall-- I beat him
two tournaments in a row,
and he-- I thought he was
going to jump overboard.
He was so mad.
DREW SCOTT: It was the paddle.
It was the crappy paddle.
JONATHAN SCOTT: If he
uses a crappy paddle,
I can still beat him.
But if he uses his fancy--
DREW SCOTT: Ninja.
JONATHAN SCOTT: --$5,000
paddle, then he can beat me.
DREW SCOTT: It is not $5,000.
ALAN SEALES: $4,999.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah, exactly.
DREW SCOTT: $180.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much
for being here.
So, I'm also an identical twin.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yay.
AUDIENCE: And a
dream of mine would
be one day to go into
business with my twin sister.
But I think we've been
a little hesitant,
because I don't think,
you know, we don't
want to drive each other crazy.
DREW SCOTT: Is her
dream very different?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, that
could be one problem.
But I wanted to
hear from you guys,
what's kind of-- from both
of your perspectives--
what's the best part about
working with your twin brother,
and what's the worst part?
DREW SCOTT: So, I would say the
best part-- he's [INAUDIBLE]
ALAN SEALES: His eyes lit
up when you said that.
DREW SCOTT: The
most important thing
is to be able--
I love him a lot.
The most important thing
is to separate emotion.
Anytime you're doing
something in business--
this is why a lot of
families can't work together
is because they're always
emotionally charged
with whatever they're doing.
This is also why homeowners--
we tell homeowners,
don't list your own house.
Don't try and GC, general
contract your own renovation.
Bring in a professional, because
we don't have the emotions.
So that's the biggest thing.
We're good at that.
Uh.
Love you, bro.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Love you, bro.
DREW SCOTT: I would say
the worst thing is that,
when we're--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well, I
think the big thing-- Our
no BS policy is a big thing.
We have a no BS policy.
We get it out before it
turns into something bad.
But the best thing
is that, if you've
had a best friend who you can
finish each other's sentences
and all that stuff-- it's
like that times a hundred
when you're an identical twin.
So he knows what I
can do in a design.
So people are always
like, (GOOFY VOICE) well,
I'm not going to ask
Drew a design question,
because Jonathan knows it.
I went-- yeah, I went to college
for construction and design,
but he knows how to
design a nice house.
So people-- we work
very well in the fact
that we know where to
share our resources.
DREW SCOTT: What's
the worst thing?
I would say the worst thing is--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Drew is
a robot who will work--
DREW SCOTT:
--third-wheeling on a date.
JONATHAN SCOTT: --24 hours
a day, always, everywhere.
We were in Paris--
they would go,
him and-- you're just as
bad, Linda, wherever the hell
you are.
They would go home at 8
o'clock every night in Paris
and work on the computer.
I'm like, we're in Paris.
We're on top of
the Eiffel Tower,
and he takes a conference call.
So--
DREW SCOTT: Really
good reception.
JONATHAN SCOTT: --that's
Drew's downside.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
Oh, yeah.
Over here.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So your work
is impeccable, of course.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: But I
imagine that there
are some people who are a
little difficult to please.
So I'm wondering
what's the least
enthusiastic or unexpected
response you've ever gotten?
DREW SCOTT: I have
one funny client.
So this is actually from season
one of "Property Brothers."
And I don't know
if you remember.
He was a little short guy--
he was a little Asian guy--
JONATHAN SCOTT: (COUGH
TALKING) Keiran.
DREW SCOTT: --with gray hair.
Do you guys remember?
Kieran was his name.
And I just found him
the funniest thing,
because he thought he was
the guru of everything.
He would come into Google
and tell all of your execs
how to do their job.
Like, that's just how he was.
And so he was bragging
to Jonathan, (SMUG VOICE)
I've been renovating
properties for years.
And then he would
be pointing out
something that is a very
generic feature that you
put in a renovation property.
And he was like,
(SMUG VOICE) I've
never seen this
ridiculous thing before.
What is this?
He would follow Jonathan around
with a tape measure, literally,
the entire renovation.
Measures this, measures that.
He would measure
the dist-- he called
it his splash radius
from the toilet,
and he would measure the
splash radius to the sink.
ALAN SEALES: Oh.
DREW SCOTT: It was the
most annoying thing to see.
JONATHAN SCOTT: He made me
reconfigure the whole bathroom
because the splash
radius was within two
inches of his allowable amount.
So.
ALAN SEALES: Did he take
personal height into account?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well,
I said, I'm like, dude,
from your height,
there's no splash.
You're in the toilet already.
So, you know, just watch
that you don't dip in.
So.
So, yeah.
Yeah, you get people like
that that are know-it-alls.
They're the ones
that are probably--
But the only other thing, too,
is I appreciate that this is
a crazy process, and it's--
the clients are paying
for the majority of the
reno on "Property Brothers,"
so that's why they
get so emotional.
But the big thing is, if we
come across a problem that
was hidden inside the walls--
and every major renovation
will come across a problem.
You hope it's something small
that your contingency covers.
But, if we find something,
and the homeowner-- and this
has happened on more
than one occasion--
says to me, (GRUFF VOICE)
well, I'm not paying for it,
but you better fix it.
You found it.
I'm like, it's your
frigging house.
What are you talking about?
DREW SCOTT: That's
not how it works.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
It's not my house.
Yeah.
So I'm not going to leave
a property that's unsafe,
but, at the same
time, homeowners
have to realize that
you, as the homeowner,
are responsible, at
the end of the day,
for the safety of the home.
And I want to make sure
that, you know, fix it.
DREW SCOTT: We can't
quote on some job
that we don't see
behind the walls.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Right.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Good question.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
follow-up and just say,
do you really make the people
remove the toilet bowls?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Hell, yeah.
DREW SCOTT: He does.
Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I'm not
touching your toilet.
DREW SCOTT: Have you ever?
Have you ever lifted a toilet?
JONATHAN SCOTT: There was
one, I think one episode.
So, my entire
career, I have always
made the homeowners carry
out their own toilets.
Because I'm not-- that's
not my goal in life is to--
[LAUGHTER]
DREW SCOTT: He made me do it.
And all I did is, I did
the whole, I went, oh!
And I did the pretend fall, and
I splashed him with the pee.
Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Sometimes you
just have to get the job done,
so I'll dive in and
[WHISTLE] right in there.
DREW SCOTT: Hand in that pee.
ALAN SEALES: Dive
into that toilet.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
I'm from a small town.
DREW SCOTT: Hold on one second.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: Can I point out
that you're blending style.
You have a Drew-style blazer
and Jonathan-style shirt.
AUDIENCE: This is not--
DREW SCOTT: Thank
you for the support.
AUDIENCE: This is
not unintentional.
[LAUGHING]
So, everyone in the
town that I'm from
has decided that I look more
like the Property Brothers
than anyone else in the town.
And so, people feel
the need to tell me--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Is the
town called Crazyville?
Is it?
What is the name of your town?
DREW SCOTT: You have the hair.
You've got the dark hair.
I see it.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so,
people come up--
ALAN SEALES: You're
tall any male.
AUDIENCE: --every time they
watch you, they're like,
oh, we watched your
brothers last night--
which is every night, all the
time, and everyone in the town.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Can
you come up here
and ask your question from up
here, so we can take a selfie?
I also-- I'm curious--
DREW SCOTT: Come
on in the middle.
ALAN SEALES: Here, here.
Want me to take your phone?
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Does your whole town
think that all tall
white guys look the same?
AUDIENCE: I think so.
ALAN SEALES: Want me
to take your picture?
JONATHAN SCOTT:
It's a racist town.
All white guys look the same.
ALAN SEALES: Something's
not happening here.
AUDIENCE: It's the east coast.
It's Canada.
It's pretty--
DREW SCOTT: You opened a chat.
ALAN SEALES: Oh.
All right.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I've spent so
much-- I've spent a ton of time
taking pictures.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
One, two, three, Google.
All right.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I almost reached
in again at the same time.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DREW SCOTT: Derek, enjoy.
Sit.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So, also we need
a video release from you,
so don't go anywhere.
AUDIENCE: No sweat.
So I've had a lot of
time to think about this.
And I'm just saying, what if
there was a long lost "Property
Brothers" episode?
Now, I don't know how
to fix anything, really.
But I could be the
drunk one on the couch.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And kind of hucking--
DREW SCOTT: Like
you are, right now.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Exactly.
And so I would be your
biggest project yet--
DREW SCOTT: I like this.
AUDIENCE: --my
emotional problems.
DREW SCOTT: So you'll be--
we'll call you Proppy.
AUDIENCE: Proppy Bro.
JONATHAN SCOTT: By the way,
did anyone see the SNL--
was it the 30th anniversary
or 40th anniversary--
DREW SCOTT: 40th anniversary.
JONATHAN SCOTT: --celebration.
Ed Norton did a
sketch in New York.
What's the name of
the guy who does
all of the club breakdowns?
I can't remember.
AUDIENCE: Stefon.
JONATHAN SCOTT: What is it?
DREW SCOTT: S--
AUDIENCE: Stefon.
AUDIENCE: Bill Hader.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Stefan, yeah.
And in that, Stefon's
like, (BREATHY VOICE)
the club was designed by
the lesser-known Property
Brother, Proppy.
That was you!
AUDIENCE: That was me.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Yeah, so that's cool.
DREW SCOTT: You know what?
Tell you what.
We will have our
agent contact you.
You don't contact them.
We will have them--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah, we'll
have them reach out to you.
Anyway, that's nice.
I would say that half of
the tweets that we get
are from people whose families
have outed them as a Property
Brother lookalike.
And so, at some point, we
need to start our own club
or something like that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DREW SCOTT: Thank you for
making yourself known to us.
The other brother.
Actually it is the
cutest thing when
we have-- our fans
will have their kids,
will post pictures,
when they want
to be us for Halloween
or something like that.
And they all fight
to be the contractor.
Like, the kids all want
ALAN SEALES: Wear the tool belt.
DREW SCOTT: Come on, [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN SCOTT: Snapchat
has a face filter
that puts a beard,
like a goatee, on you.
And everyone now looks like me.
I had a 10-year-old send a
picture with the beard on now,
and it looks like me.
So apparently it's that Jonathan
filter on Snapchat right now.
ALAN SEALES: You need to
have your Realtor toolbelt.
DREW SCOTT: I do.
I mean--
ALAN SEALES: So it's pink.
DREW SCOTT: I would say,
I don't need a tool belt,
because I just carry a tool
around with me all the time.
ALAN SEALES: Ba-dum-bump.
DREW SCOTT: I'm sorry.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
A question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned that you're
currently not in Manhattan,
or you have only done a
limited number of projects.
So my question is
what are your--
JONATHAN SCOTT: Will you
marry me, is that what?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm
already married.
But my question is what are your
reservations with Manhattan?
Because Manhattan can be tricky.
And, if there were,
hypothetically,
were a rooftop project in
Harlem that needed to be redone,
is that-- you know--
DREW SCOTT: Hypothetically?
AUDIENCE: --something you
would be interested in.
DREW SCOTT: Well,
the main thing is,
we always have to think about--
there is the real estate
side of what we do.
And we love hitting
all different cities
to show the country-- the
diversity of properties
across the country.
But the other side is
the production side.
We have to think logistically.
Shooting in Manhattan
gets very, very expensive.
Because think about parking for
crew vehicles and everything.
Construction, if you're
dealing with downtown property,
it gets really expensive.
JONATHAN SCOTT: There's
timelines for permits.
Co-ops turnaround.
Co-ops have to approve
everything that you do,
and they only meet once a month.
So if you don't get
approval on this one,
if there's anything wrong--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN SCOTT: --a month later.
So the problem that I
have is the timeline.
Now, so if I have to be in
and out in three months,
good luck renovating anything
in Manhattan in three months.
And as far as a rooftop
patio, I actually
just did a phenomenal
rooftop patio design
here for an actor
friend of ours.
And then he ended up selling
the place before I did it.
So I have a finished
design for a rooftop patio.
Just saying.
DREW SCOTT: Rrrr.
Is, uh--
JONATHAN SCOTT:
Party at your place.
DREW SCOTT: --that proposal
back on the table, now?
JONATHAN SCOTT: That's the one
great thing with Manhattan.
Any time you're working
with a smaller space,
try and utilize your outdoor
living area for something
that you can use
throughout the year.
I mean, of course, in Vegas, we
can use an outdoor space right
through the winter.
Yours is a lot more limited,
but even in some of the designs,
you could have a reduced
area with some coverage
that'll allow to
keep the snow away.
So.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
So we've got time for
one more question.
Yeah?
JONATHAN SCOTT:
No pressure, but.
ALAN SEALES: No pressure.
Better be good.
JONATHAN SCOTT: By
the way, there's
no such thing as
a stupid question.
But if you do ask
a stupid question,
we'll make fun of you.
AUDIENCE: You'll let me know.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah,
we'll make fun of you.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Fair game.
So you mentioned that
there's lots of differences,
and different
markets and cities.
And, as someone
who's potentially
going to be a first-time
buyer in Westchester-- I live
in the city with
my husband now--
do you have any watch-outs,
call-outs that you would say
are unique to Westchester?
Now that you've been there--
both with the buy side
and the reno side.
DREW SCOTT: Can I swear?
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: Old shitty houses.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: That's very
common in Westchester.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Well,
the one thing that we did
discover-- because
we-- so we shot
for five months in Westchester
and actually all the way
up to Connecticut--
but there are
all these pockets with the
most bizarre codes that I
have come across.
The strangest
things that-- like,
I have renovated houses across
the country, up in Canada,
everywhere-- and
there will be, like,
this little hamlet
in Westchester that
has some random code
that, like, no you can't
do this because of XYZ in the
code says you have to do this.
So be aware that renovating
in Westchester was trickier.
The permits were more expensive.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN SCOTT: And they
would shut us down constantly
if you were working a minute
past the time that you
were allowed to work past.
So in normal areas where I can
work until maybe 9:00 at night,
10:00 at night,
sometimes, in Westchester
it was something
crazy like 7 o'clock.
DREW SCOTT: Sometimes, from one
county or one city to the next,
the small tweaks to code is
so drastically different.
And, as well, state to state.
So just know it inside and out.
Or hopefully if you're
working with a contractor that
knows what they're doing.
JONATHAN SCOTT: I also did
find that as soon as you tell
a trade, oh, you're coming
to Westchester to work,
they're like, sweet,
I'm charging more.
So be aware.
AUDIENCE: My father's
a contractor,
but he's licensed
in Rockland, so.
DREW SCOTT: Oh, OK.
Well, good luck.
He'll probably
charge you triple.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yes.
DREW SCOTT: Yeah, good luck.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
we are at time here.
"Dream Home" came
out today, right?
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yes.
DREW SCOTT: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Yes, so
you in the room here
are some of the first in
the world to own this book.
JONATHAN SCOTT: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: And it sold out
before the event even started.
JONATHAN SCOTT:
It did, and if you
didn't get a copy,
by the way, or if you
have family that wants to
come and get a copy, tonight
we're going to be at the
Union Square Barnes and Noble
at 7 o'clock.
We're doing a meet and greet.
We're going to sign books.
We're going to say, hello,
answer some more questions.
So that's nice and close.
So if any of you want
to come down there,
we're going to pack the place
and have a bunch more fun.
DREW SCOTT: Do me a favor.
Everyone, grab a
photo with the book.
Post it online.
Help us spread the
word a little bit.
I mean, we want to
go to number one.
We put a lot of heart
and soul into the book.
And, I mean, it's
already number one
on Amazon, which
is really amazing.
ALAN SEALES: Is it really?
DREW SCOTT: It's amazing, yeah.
So, thanks, to
everyone who bought.
But--
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: We're going
to do some autograph
signing, some photos,
and, again, you
can get the book anywhere.
Go anywhere.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
DREW SCOTT: It's better than
Jon, and it talks back less.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
All right.
Thank you.
DREW SCOTT: Thank you, other
brother from another mother.
ALAN SEALES: You even
took my whole closing.